alain de bois toujours en plateau aziz
senni déjà rejoint bonsoir sauf disais
tout à l'heure en introduction des
missions vous êtes l'auteur de
l'ascencion l'ascenseur social est en
panne j'ai pris l'escalier mon ton biz
également c'est un petit guide à
l'attention des jeunes de banlieues qui
deviennent chefs d'entreprise est les
dix commandements ou pour pour eux vous
avez fondé également à ta france société
de taxis collectifs pour les entreprises
et les particuliers vous êtes l'un des
membres fondateurs de l'ue d iran charge
des questions de sécurité auprès de jean
louis borloo votre livre l'ascenseur
social est en panne remonte à 2005
aujourd'hui 2013 le constat est le même
pour vous j'ai presque envie de dire
l'ascenseur social est toujours en panne
et il ya plus de monde dans l'escalier
aujourd'hui la question de la mobilité
sociale est au coeur du débat
l'espoir l'envi le rêve de se dire que
mes enfants vivront une vie meilleure
que la mienne est ce que les français
répondent mieux cette question en 2013
quand en 2005 j'ai pas le sentiment
la crise a renforcé un certain nombre de
situations graves particulièrement dans
les zones urbaines sensibles et en
banlieue pour prendre cet escalier
aujourd'hui est de plus en plus de monde
le chômage et même quand on est diplômé
même quand on a été à l'école même quand
on a de l'expérience et ça nous créé
aussi des situations de fuite des
cerveaux puisqu'on a aussi des départs
vers les états unis la péninsule
arabique ou l'asie on vous a réuni tous
les deux ce soir sur ce plateau puisque
avant de voir le sous titre de votre
livre c'est pourquoi les jeunes des
banlieues doivent toujours justifié
d'avoir du talent c'est ça voilà c'est
une thématique qui ce qui se rejoint
lorsque vous entendez aziz senni évoqué
ces difficultés aussi lorsque vous avez
fondé votre entreprise on y reviendra
peut-être en 2000 puisque vous avez
grandi à mantes la jolie
partagez cet avis là il est difficile
pour des jeudis du coup de l'escalier ya
même plus de rampe c'est à dire que on
est plusieurs essais essayait vraiment
casse gueule donc
euh oui je suis d'accord parce que moi
je trouve insupportable aujourd'hui que
notre société française lenôtre ne fasse
pas plus qu'à de l'intelligence j'ai
l'impression que la banlieue est en
jachère qui a ici des gens du brillant
moi j'en croise souvent qu'ils ne sont
qui n'ont pas la possibilité mais qui
sont vraiment brillant et que l'avenir
de notre pays ils passent par là
aujourd'hui
il passera pas ailleurs c'est pas
forcément faisant à chaud c'est qu'on
réussit et que et que forcément les gens
qui vont apporter à ce pays ils sont
aussi en banlieue et ils n'ont pas
justifié
ils n'ont pas justifié dans dix ans ils
ont juste à regarder ses compétences ses
talents qui lie à la et donne aux
joueurs la possibilité de ne pas prendre
l'escalier de pau prend les shales de
pas prendre la corde de dial est normal
vous disiez tout à l'heure vous avons à
vous avez notamment révélé à jamel on en
parlait tout à l'heure vous disais c'est
une erreur statistique
quand on préparait un peu cet entretien
quand on citait ces grands noms qui ont
réussi ce sont des erreurs statistiques
pour aujourd'hui que ce soit d'ailleurs
en banlieue ou dans les zones rurales il
ya beaucoup de similitudes mais 60 à peu
près 60% des enfants d'ouvriers
deviennent leurs ouvriers à leur tour
pendant ce temps-là 50% des enfants
d'énarques ont des parents énarques
on est dans un pays de castes où les
hélices les élites se reproduisent entre
elles et les couches populaires aussi
donc la difficulté que nous avons tous
ensemble les politiques les chefs
d'entreprises des acteurs sociaux les
syndicats c'est comment on fait pour que
celui qui est en bas par le mérite par
le travail par l'école puisse se dire un
jour avec tout ça je peux arriver au 2e
ou 3e au 4e étage
et pourquoi pas tout en haut de la tour
france mais aujourd'hui c'est très très
compliqué on y arrive beaucoup mieux
dans le pays de l'oncle sam ou du tonton
chang là-bas à pékin doit s'intéresser à
la fin parce qu'on parle des banlieues
des difficultés quand on vient de la
banlieue en france dans les autres pays
vous constatez pas c'est ça fonctionne
pas pareil
aujourd'hui le rêve américain le fameux
rêve américain
j'ai le sentiment qu'il est plus facile
de rentrer comme pousseurs de chariots
distribuer le courrier dans une
compagnie américaine et de se dire un
jour je serai au 40e étage et d'y
arriver sur ses compétences en france si
vous n'avez pas fait polytechnique
si vous n'avez pas fait l'ena avant de
présider un conseil d'administration
d'une entreprise du cac 40
il va en passer un petit peu d'eau sous
les ponts et la culture c'est pareil
d'ailleurs on réussir tu vois un artiste
qui débutera culture vous allez
retrouver les mêmes énarque vous alerte
où vous allez vous allez retrouver des
gens qui sortent d'écoles
d'administration ou autres qui sont à la
tête de parce que c'est des communicants
et qui vont on va mettre des
communicants à la tête de deux laissés
prendre
l'artiste que ça fonctionne partout dans
la salle de l'europe par exemple ou même
un artiste qui auraient du talent est ce
qu'il a plus de chances d'émerger s'il
est dans un autre pays et qu'il ya une
banlieue dans un quartier moins connu
que s'il est en france que je sais pas
j'ai vraiment passé de connaissances à
je peux pas me permettre de parler de
pays que je ne connais pas j'essaie déjà
de connaître le mien et c'est déjà assez
compliqué que les apparatchiks qui soit
où elle ou l'établissement culturel en
france il est d'une dune d'une rudesse
incroyable
et que oui on aussi fouettée moi je sais
ce que je dis est à l'heure ainsi avec
insurrection culturel à partir de ce
soir message est passé
on va juste faire une pause donner la
parole aux yvelinois aux saint
quentinois nous leur avons posé la
question nous lui avons demandé s'il
considérait qu'il était justement plus
difficile de s'en sortir de réussir
lorsqu'on venait de la banlieue il me
semble que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
pour un jeune de banlieue effectivement
trouver du travail en fonction
effectivement si c'est comment je
pourrais dire des trucs qu'ils soient
étrangers ou pas vu la situation rôle en
ce moment là c'est pas être retrouvé
libre pour tous ces jeunes de se tasser
incorporé effectivement dans l'eure dans
leur milieu et puis eux de trouver du
fait du travail facilement je pense que
ils sont un petit peu négligé en fait je
suis professeur des écoles sera et dans
une école où justement il ya cette
mixité entre des jeunes favoriser des
jeunes défavorisés on voit très
clairement qu'il y en a qui s'en sortent
plus ou pas parce que les moyens à la
maison sont pas les mêmes parce que
l'argent effectivement il ya besoin
d'argent pour avoir de l'aide
malheureusement et qu' ils ont pas
forcément cette aide a donc je pense que
oui encore aujourd'hui même si on essaye
maintenant de réduire cet écart je pense
que encore c'est difficile plus
difficile de s'en sortir quand les
jeunes défendent avec dirais que non
parce que maintenant à l'école est
ouverte à tous donc pour un jeune de
banlieue où un jeune qui est un peu plus
aisés et non à 6 heures il y aura des
meilleures écoles avec l'argent dans ce
soit plus difficile je pense qu'il faut
se donner juste le moyen quoi mais je
pense que les jeunes des banlieues ont
justement ce côté déterminée et que
que je pense que les jeunes de banlieue
peuvent accomplir même beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses avec la détermination
et la vente à l'on va dire et faire
confiance surtout surtout faire
confiance parce que voilà il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui sont déterminés comme je
vous dis et qui ont un vécu le même
cerveau que mais que d'un autre gars
quoi on a les mêmes capacités
si ce n'est plus des fois donc voila
quoi je pense que la chance est donnée à
tout le monde donc voilà avoir de la
confiance
beaucoup de confiance en soi c'est aussi
le travail que vous menez la confiance
en soi pour reprendre jamais elle même
si c'est qu'une exception il m'a dit ce
que tu m'apportes et c'est de la
considération
c'est déjà avoir de la considération
pour l'individu l'être humain vous avez
en face de vous avant de lui mettre tout
sur le dos de de la considération ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est ma culture c'est
qu'est ce que tu as à me dire et bien tu
leur as compte bien où ces mots là son
étonnant je n'avais pas entendu
et ça me fais pas ça me parle autrement
et par continue écrit revient demain
revient la semaine prochaine on
retravaille là-dessus va aussi c'est pas
parce que c'est la preuve qu'on ne peut
pas être exigeant c'est aussi une
exigence qu'on a vis-à-vis des uns et
des autres et de la considération la
considération il a raison cet homme
voilà voilà une fois qu'on sera
d'essayer on sera tous avec le même
squelette 1 c'est pas c'est pas le souci
aujourd'hui c'est vous allez cette
considération
elle passe aussi par les financements et
passe par des choix politiques
donc grâce à faire et c'est finalement
au choix politiques à l'occasion de la
sortie de votre livre alain degois à
médine trappe vous intéresser à ces
jeunes des banlieues à ces
dysfonctionnements que vous avez
constaté depuis trente ans sur le
terrain et on s'y intéresse également ce
soir aziz senni vous êtes politique
également je le dise en présentation
donc de lui d y soutient d'hervé morin
aussi par le passé on vous avez reçu à
cette occasion
quelle responsabilité pour les
politiques aujourd'hui et surtout
quelles actions à mettre en place le
discours qu'ils soient politiques ou
celui du citoyen pour moi il va être le
même c'est que vous avez deux
responsabilités vous en avez eu une
quête individuelle dans le titre de mon
livre l'ascenseur social est en panne
c'est une responsabilité collective
lorsque dans ces quartiers où en zone
rurale vous avez de jeunes professeurs
qui sont nommés et donc de ce fait
peut-être une éducation nationale moins
qualitatif qu'ailleurs il ya une preuve
une problématique qui est lié à
état aux politiques mais de l'autre côté
vous avez aussi une responsabilité
individuelle
il s'agit pas de tomber dans des clichés
de victimisation on se dire oh les
pauvres d'ailleurs qu'ils soient noirs
arabes blanc dans ses quartiers au le
petit discours touche pas à mon pote
post-colonialiste etc
non il ya une responsabilité
individuelle l'ascenseur social est en
panne d'accord mais tu prend l'escalier
oui c'est injuste oui c'est très
compliqué oui ça ne devrait pas exister
police malheureusement simplifiée
justement cette ascension sociale assez
par des soit ils peuvent la simplifier à
travers des choix qu'elle peuvent-ils il
ya l'éducation
bien évidemment il ya une vraie réforme
de fond à faire sur les écoles en
matière surtout de gestion du personnel
et d'attribution d'affectation des
postes ensuite il ya la confiance qu'on
disait tout à l'heure lorsque vous avez
dans des collèges ou des lycées attrape
à mantes-la-jolie chez moi la fédération
du bâtiment où les usines à flins ou
renault renault flins et peugeot poissy
qui viennent vous expliquer qu'on manque
de bras il faudrait aussi donner de
l'espoir à ces gamins et leur envoyer
des chefs d'entreprise que le medef la
cgpme a expliqué qu'on peut être chef
d'entreprise avocat donner de l'espoir
donner du rêve
vous savez le yes we can d'obama
pourquoi ne nous l'avons pas appliquer à
nous-mêmes
ici en france moi je pense que c'est
aussi le rôle du politique votre avis
alors de voir sur le rôle du politique
on l'a le rôle du politique je sais que
j'aimais me connaissez mais mais mais
emportements parfois sans vous emporter
dans la table on regarde la tête fois je
pense que non le politique
il a le pouvoir qui lui a attribué de
façon démocratique et que à un moment
donné il y à des choix
nous sommes encore un pays riche il y a
des choix à faire ils sont urgents et il
y est c'est à lui de décider
il a le pouvoir moi j'ai pas ce pouvoir
là je veux juste lui dire il faut le
faire faites-le elle est dans ce sens là
écoutez nous faites nous confiance parce
que il ya des politiques qui ne font
plus confiance qu'à eux mêmes même pas
l'entendre
voilà retrouvons cette confiance envers
les gens entre les citoyens de notre
pays et peut-être aussi
ben oui vous êtes vous êtes au pouvoir
vous devez donner l'exemple et ben on
vous écoute on vous regarde et le rôle
comment vous est donné tous les deux
aujourd'hui puisque vous avez réussi
dans vos branches respectives c'est
d'aider aussi les autres vous avez fondé
par exemple les business angels des
cités c'est un fonds d'investissement
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que en
tout cas pour ces territoires
les zones rurales je répète et les zones
urbaines sensibles
il ya un levier sur lequel nous n'avons
pas suffisamment travaillé qui pour moi
le levier majeur avec l'éducation c'est
le levier du travail de l'emploi et des
entreprises à se développer
il n'y a pas d'emploi sans employeur
donc aider des entreprises des pme en
particulier à se développer c'est dans
ce cadre que j'ai créé business angel
des cités un fonds d'investissement nous
avons 15 millions que nous investissons
dans des pme qui se situent dans les
zones urbaines sensibles afin de les
aider à se développer et une entreprise
que se développe c'est une entreprise
qui recrute et qui recrutent d'abord
dans ces territoires
vous savez chez moi au val fourré c'est
50 % de taux de chômage chez les moins
de 30 ans comment vous pouvez espérer
réussir un avenir meilleur avec 50% de
jeunes au chômage
mais on marche sur la tête donc il ya
des urgences il faut revenir peut-être
un petit peu aux basiques l'éducation de
l'emploi
c'est ultra urgentissime par déclic
théâtre on parle souvent quand on parle
de déclic théâtre des succès des grandes
réussites de djamel d'arnaud tsamère on
et revient régulièrement
pour autant ce n'est pas uniquement de
travail que vous menez non non non dire
que le clip est assez des milliers de
jeunes s'est passé pas cela et là c'est
la cerise sur le gâteau c'est celui qui
a été plus loin c'est suite d'une passe
ne s'oriente pas forcément vers une
carrière artistique après voilà il
s'oriente aussi vers autre chose
c'est autant de plaisir à voir le retour
d'un jeune homme de jeune fille qui dit
papy trace grâce à grâce à l'impro j'ai
passé mes euros de bach et j'ai tout
cartonner ou nounous timmins voir écoute
lâchant quand dans une école de commerce
deskom vous travaillez avec les écoles
et les collèges également on imagine que
ça se ressent peut-être sur leurs
résultats scolaires ça leur redonne
confiance il il travaille mieux on tombe
toujours toute cette confiance saisir
que quelqu'un qui s'aperçoit que sa
parole peut être entendu
et que d'un seul coup on peut l'écouter
il va s'en servir il va se dire maintien
du coup j'ai ça en moi et et je sais pas
je ne suis pas là pour régler les
problèmes sociaux
je suis là juste pour leur dire vous
avez cette possibilité on vous d'être
artiste et la créativité l'imaginaire et
peut se mettre au service d'une société
d'une idée que j'avais cette idée là bas
avec ton imaginaire que tu as pu
développer en impro peut-être que du
coup cette idée battu à savoir la porte
et la défendre savais tu montais
d'aimables sa boîte montée être me
progressé dans l'entreprise ne pas oser
de vous et allez voir de pas se faire
écraser par une hiérarchie deuxième et
moi j'ai du talent j'ai ça en plus de
ces le dire je sais le faire je sais
bien mon ma peau si déjà moi j'arrive à
ça c'est énorme
et puis voilà moi je suis je pense qu'il
ya de l'éducation je pense que la
culture est une culture ouverte laïque à
la porte et tous est nécessaire
aujourd'hui il nécessaire pour conclure
votre plus grande fierté c'est quoi de
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui la personnalité
préférée des français par exemple c'est
omar sy jamel debbouze figure aussi en
bonne place
ça veut dire qu'il ya une reconnaissance
aussi de la part de la france de tous
les français de ces jeunes qui viennent
des banlieues puis c'est surprenant
parce que si on n'avait pas dire c'est
que ce pays est raciste et tout ça
n'empêche que vous prenez le quarteron
de tête des dés
dépose des préférés des français
je suis désolé ils sont comme d'origine
pas gauloise et pourtant bah c'est quand
même eux les préférées et que les gens
donc s'identifient à eux les
reconnaissent comme étant faisant partie
des leurs ben voilà c'est tout la france
s à sa séance est d'accord en un mot
très brièvement puisqu'on doit conclure
cette émission sur 7
justement cette carte est aussi de voir
qu'aujourd'hui à des choses qui sent
aussi évolué tout de même bien sûr
heureusement avec tout le travail qui
est fait heureusement alors bien
évidemment on regrette
il regrette toujours que ça ne va pas
assez vite mais ce que je voudrais aussi
en conclusion c'est surtout dire qu'il
ne faut pas évacuer aussi ce qui ne va
pas dans l'est dans les banlieues il ya
des tas de choses qui ne vont pas mais
je laisse ça aux vrp de la haine au vrp
de la colère au vrp de la dépression et
c'est ce que j'ai envie c'est de donner
du rêve et faire rêver les gamins ce que
voudrait vous sera le modef un rêve
voilà l'ambition le travail et le
partage on est en ile de france ratp
voilà très bien parfait merci beaucoup a
dit sony pour cette conclusion merci
également à alain degois je rappelle aux
actualités respectives
aziz senni on va vous voir souvent avec
lui dès le travail qui vous attend pour
les prochaines élections et puis vos
deux ouvrages l'ascenseur social est en
panne et montres ton biz
alain degois médine trappe mercier à
tous les deux c'est la fin de cette
édition du 7 8 je vous retrouve demain
en direct à 18h